hi welcome to phi data global 2021 i am
there and i i will be your host
i will introduce
our speaker daniel thompson
uh dan is a full stack developer and
tech lead with a love for python
and he creates nice user interfaces
he is based in the uk and started his
career after picking up a second
handbook on html
which sparked a lifelong interest in
building digital products
he is often phone tinkering with
websockets
postgres and a simsio
yeah thank you very much for the intro
all right so welcome to this talk it's
about managing your data with fast api
and piccolo admin
so first of all what's fast api so
apologies to people who have already
used fast api but i'll just give a quick
overview
so it's a modern web framework that
makes building swagger docs for your
rest api very simple
and it's an asynchronous web framework
based around the ascii standard
so people who've built web applications
in the past are probably familiar with
wsgi well this is just the async
equivalent of that
and there's quite a lot of frameworks
built around that standard so it's quite
an exciting space
and as i've described here it's the new
hotness
as you can see from the github stars
it's grown tremendously in the last year
in the bottom right you can see the
swagger docs that fast api will generate
for you automatically
so during this talk we're gonna go
through that with a little demo
and then next what's piccolo so it's an
async query build an orm with lots of
batteries included
and it works primarily with postgres but
then it also works with sql light as
well
so it integrates really nicely with fast
api and other ascii frameworks
because piccolo was built from the
ground up to have great async support
and we originally started the project
because there was a lack of asynchrons
at the time
and i have a design agency background
and having a really high quality admin
interface was very important for me and
for my clients so we put a lot of effort
into that
and then i just got the nice little
postgres logo on the bottom because it's
so beautiful
and then in the bottom left you can see
this is a little screen grab of how
piccolo admin looks
and so let's just talk about this async
matter
so async i o was added in python 3.5
but then it was quite difficult at first
it didn't have support for async and
await and that was added in python 3.6
and i think that really kind of unlocked
it for the community and made it much
easier to use
and async io is an approach to
concurrency based on an event loop and
co routines
so what happens is
when you use the await keyword python
will pause that co routine and then
it'll resume another core routine so
rather than using threads and relying on
the operating system to manage the
concurrency for you you can just let the
event loop do it
and so async is useful when you're io
bound so good examples are talking to a
database or an api call
and so
typically with your architecture you'll
have web application servers and you'll
have a database on a separate server and
so by the time you've got the network
lag or https
and postgres itself doing the job
then you do have a few milliseconds and
even though python's not the fastest
language in the world async i o can
still be useful
and here async isn't essential for all
applications so if you're cpu bound
then
it doesn't help particularly but if you
need high throughput applications and
you're talking to a lot of laggy
services then async io's really
great and why postgres so i'm talking to
a data conference i'm sure you all love
postgres just as much as i do
um
so piccolo mostly supports postgres
we decided to really
buckle down on postgres support because
it is such an excellent database and it
is so feature-rich
and so postgres continues to grow um it
went dbms the year in 2020
and
even though it's been around for so long
the feature support is really remarkable
so it can support json
gis
using the post.js extension
and more recently time series via
timescale db
so the hope is we can support a lot of
these features in the future with
piccolo
so
let's code an ascii app so even though
piccolo is an orm it comes with a
command line interface and it has a
command to create a web application so
i'm just going to demo this really
quickly
so
um i'm just going to run a docker
container
and so imagine now you are starting from
scratch for piccolo
um you just need to do pip install
piccolo
[Music]
so this is going to install piccolo and
all its dependencies and what we're
going to do next is we're going to demo
the piccolo command line interface
and the piccolo ascii new command if
you've ever used django it's very
similar to that where you can start an
app and it
it creates a template for you but the
difference with piccolo is it supports
lots of different ascii frameworks and
as these servers so it's a little bit
more flexible so we're trying to be
um
trying to support as many other
libraries as we can
okay so i'm just going to create a
directory now called my app
i'll just make it slightly bigger
oops
and then if i use the piccolo cli
you'll see here all the options so
piccolo has quite a lot of options out
of the box but the one we're interested
in is asking you
so let's give that a go
and you'll see here that we can pick
which routing framework we want so the
starlet fast api and black sheep at the
moment and clearly as this is a fast api
demo we're going to pick fast api
and then we're going to pick uvicorn as
the ascii
and this just tells us how to get
started we just install the requirements
python main dot py and then we're good
to go
so i'll just do ls and show you here
here are some of the files
and then the main entry point is app.py
and you can see here that it's created a
fast api app for us
with some end points
so what i'm going to do next so let's
just hop back
to the slides
so this screen grab here is when you run
python main dot py this is the screen
you'll see when you load up in your
server so it tells you all the steps you
need to take in terms of setting up a
postgres database
so what i've done for this talk is i've
taken that basic template and i've
expanded upon it and i've created pi mdb
clearly i am db but far better let's be
honest because it's written in python
so
it uses this schema it's a little bit
small but we have movies
each movie has a director and then we
have reviews so a user might say this
movie is great it's moody's terrible and
then we have the sessions and the base
user for authentication
so we're going to have a look at the
code now
so i'm just going to exit this and we're
going to jump over to vs code
okay so
let me just tell you a little bit about
the template and how this all works so
i've got a main.py here and this is the
main entry point into our application so
this uses uvicorn which is our web
server and then we just give it the path
to an ascii application
and this ascii application lives inside
app.py
so at the top we have a bunch of imports
nothing too exciting there
you'll see here we instantiate a fast
api app and anyone that's used flask in
the past will feel very at home with
fast api
so we also define these routes
so here we've got a home endpoint
and this is basically rendering a ginger
template
so
so we've just got our basic kind of
hello world page
and then if we go back to app dot py
we also mount the admin
so this is piccolo admin now and it's
really easy to create this all we have
to do is provide it with a bunch of
piccolo tables
and we can see here in tables.py
here we've defined all of our tables
so if you've used an orm in the past
then this will feel very comfortable
and with piccolo the column types are
the same as in sql so if you know sql
there's no kind of second guessing
what's the column name for their car
it's just fair car
so yeah we defined our tables
and then so we've got director we've got
a movie with some options it's all very
modern python like using enums
we're using the new syntax for
meta classes so you can pass arguments
in
um we have a studio and a review
so let's hop back to app.py
and then we also mount static
so we can serve our static files the
reason we have this is so we can serve
the css for the home page
all right then so
let's talk about pedantic now so a big
part of the puzzle with fast api is
pedantic and it's a serialization
library which is really fantastic
so it's it's very performance and it's
very easy to use
and if you've used python data classes
before you'll feel right at home
so here i've defined a pedantic model
and as you can see this is very similar
to data class notation
so
piccolo has a feature called create
pedantic model so even though
pi dynasty is great and you can define
your models fairly quickly there's kind
of no point if you've already defined
your database tables
so
with create pedantic model all you have
to do is reference a piccolo table and
it automatically creates a pedantic
model which is a huge time saver
especially as you have if you have a
table with lots of columns
and here because we're creating multiple
models
based on the same table we have to give
it a
name and the reason we create multiple
pedantic models is
when a user post data
we don't expect them to say post the id
of the new row
so this is why
but then when we serialize out in a get
request we will include the the id
so this is why we have
multiple pedantic models
okay so moving on from that this is how
fast api works so again
if you've used flask you'll feel super
familiar
we have the decorator syntax
we give it the path and slash reviews
and then
the response model is the pedantic model
that's going to return
and then the tags will group common
endpoints together in the swagger docs
so this is a really simple one we're
just getting all of the reviews
and this is returning
a list of dictionaries but what fast api
does is it sees that the response model
is a list of these review model our
pedantic models and automatically create
converts the list of dictionaries into a
list of pedantic models and then
serializes it out as
json next we've got get review so
here we'll see a little bit more fast
api syntax you can put here we've got
review id in the url as a url parameter
and what happens is you can define them
here in the function
arguments and the type annotation here
is an int and that what's really cool
this fast api will then convert it from
a string into an integer
and so here we're basically getting the
review with a matching id if it doesn't
exist we return four or four
otherwise we return the review
so moving on to create review so
again here's some new fast api syntax
you can define a model
as a function argument and what happens
was fast api will then take the json
payload or the form data
and it will then serialize a pedantic
model
and then if there's any issues with the
data it will then return a 400 error so
um it does all that validation for you
and all you need to worry about is you
just get the model
so what we're doing here is we're
unpacking the model into a table we're
saving it and then we're returning
the dictionary
so again just
fast api does some amazing things with
um type annotations
okay
no need to go into too much detail with
this one this is just um a put
we have a patch um i don't think there's
any more
new fast api syntax to discuss
and then we've got our delete okay so as
you can see fast api is quite easy to
work with these are all quite succinct
and you you get a lot of functionality
for fairly little code
but then if you're building a huge api
with lots of tables it can still become
quite tedious so we have this
alternative in piccolo called fast api
wrapper
and what this will do is replicate all
of this functionality
and more
just in a few lines of code
so all we need to do is give it the fast
api app
we have this thing called piccolo crud
in piccolo which is really kind of the
magic source behind all the api stuff
and what it will do is you give it a
picture table and it creates all of the
endpoints
and then we can pass fast api arguments
as well so if we wanted to replicate
this functionality with the tags
we can also do that
and then finally we have a connection
pool
so one thing to be aware of when using
an async rm is you can quickly exhaust
the number of connections that the
database has available
so by default postgres will say have a
hundred
so it's really important to have either
an internal
connection pool or an external one like
pg bouncer that way once you've
exhausted the connections they will then
just wait to get a connection rather
than just failing
okay so there's a quick overview of fast
api and pedantic so we're going to hop
back to the presentation
ah this is in the way of my play button
okay
so all of that code is available on
github so feel free to browse that after
this talk
okay so next we're on to the swagger
docs
so this is really like one of the great
bits of functionality
so now we're looking at our swagger docs
so here these are all the ones that we
defined by hand
so here i can um try this out
so here we get all the reviews
and i can also create reviews
and what's really nice about it as well
is it
it kind of know it kind of tells you
what to expect back as well
so this is really clever
so
this is the one we created with the fast
api wrapper and you'll see here this
this has lots of endpoints has lots of
kind of free functionality
so if we were to get all of the movies
let's keep this
and here we have all the movies
snakes on the plane clearly great film
um
but what you'll notice here
is
for each of the columns in the piccolo
table
you can
filter
but then it also has an operator which
is really powerful
so you can do stuff like not only
give me the row which matches this id
but give me the rows where the id is
greater than x
and
it's really useful in this example
because let's imagine with ratings
i want to say
give me every film but the rating is
greater than 90.
clearly snakes on the plane isn't gonna
get returned but we do have
lord of the rings
lord of the rings clearly those rings
some great films
um
danielle
yep
yes there are some questions already in
the q a section
i don't know if you can see them
i can't see them whilst i'm presenting
um let me see
oh let me get the chat up
um
i can't see them is it in slack or in um
no no here they are hearing soon i can't
see them at the bottom
i'll
send it to you to the chat to the chat
i'm sorry okay thanks
um
because we've only got 10 minutes left
as well i'll i might just power through
them at the end
okay thank you thank you all right cool
thank you
okay so let's move on from that
um so go back to our slides
and then next we're going to show
piccolo admin
so just log in
so here's pi mdb
so create admin created all this ui for
us for free
um so in the sidebar we have
all of the tables we have the directors
the movies the reviews
the studio
and then
the other way um
so as i showed before
because we have so much functionality
exposed in that rest api
we make use of it here so we have all
these really powerful filters
um in the ui so for example we can say
give me every film that lasts longer
than three hours
and then i can apply this
and then here i've got
again a bunch of lord of the rings films
clearly the best and the longest
and then we have some other
functionality as well like you can have
light mode
if you prefer that
um
personally i find this easier on my eyes
and then you can sort
so i wanted to sort by
um
name
and then you've also got export csv
so when i worked um for a design agency
every client wanted to export csv all
the time so it's here out the box
okay so that's piccolo admin so just
jump back quickly just where your time
um
okay so
we've got something running very quickly
but what if you want to do more complex
queries um using piccolo so it's a fully
fledged rm and query builder so i just
want to show you some of the other
features that i'm quite proud of
so this one's called playground and it's
an ipython shell but then it uses sqlite
with an embedded schema and data
so
even if you're very very new to piccolo
and databases in general if you just use
piccolo playground run then you've got
everything you need to start
experimenting with queries
so i'm going to hop back to my docker
container
and then i'm going to run piccolo
playground run
and then this is a different schema now
this is about fictional bands and their
managers
as you can see here it's automatically
created all these database tables
and then we can experiment with queries
so i can do
so run sync what this does is it runs it
synchronously
but then i can also
await
so this is a bit of
uh ipython magic it lets you do top
level weight um you usually have to do
inside a co-routine and then you can
also emit the run if you like as well so
this also works
um and then we can do joins so i can do
manager.name
um
and then i can do stuff like where
band.popularity
is greater than 500.
[Music]
i'll also get the uh name one second
so as you can see the the playground's a
great way of just learning about uh the
piccolo syntax and also databases in
general really because you can also do
kind of raw sequel
so i'm going to exit this
i'm going to hop back to the
presentation
um
so
other batteries
so piccolo's got other batches included
as well so it's got automatic database
migrations authentication
cli commands
schema generation so if you're coming
from an existing postgres database we
have a piccolo schema generate and what
this will try and do is create all of
the
piccolo tables
written in python so you can interact
with an existing database
and then we have piccolo schema graph as
well
and what that does is it visualizes your
schema using graphis
so i just want to show something else
very quickly so
and then we'll get to questions
so
as i showed the playground before
you can also do the same inside your own
app
so going back to pi mdb i can do
piccolo shell run
and this imports all of the tables and
so just as i was experimenting in the
playground i can experiment here with my
own custom schema so i can do movie dot
select
okay um and that's it for
i'll jump to questions because we're
running long time already
okay so
yeah i'd love people to get involved so
any feedback you have is welcome and we
have an active github community we're
open to new contributors
so yeah i'd love everyone to check the
project out
and yeah thank you very much and um yeah
hopefully take some questions
i hope i got
uh
oh how to bite a blobs appear in piccolo
admin
um
so we've got support for like uh normal
bytes
um
so yeah we do i think we convert them to
um just normal strings
but there are some things which are
really challenging to build an ap like
an element around but we kind of do our
best
um
science going back through the questions
could you elaborate a bit on what are
the key differences between your setup
and django
besides the pedantic
serialization so it is very similar to
django um but then it's kind of async
first so
if that's really important for you so
for example a lot of the apps i build
are kind of chat apps
and real time is really important
so you might want to look at something
more like fast api
and piccolo and then obviously they're
also api first so
you can add apis on top of django but
then they're not kind of natively built
in so i don't think there's a faster way
at the moment of building an api than
fast api
um so those would be my main reasons for
maybe picking these rather than django
um how easy is it to use auth with the
fast api wrapper
okay so
we have a bunch of authentication out of
the box so
fast api is built on top of starlet
which is an ascii library
and then what happens is piccolo has a
bunch of middleware so we have
um
session middleware and token middleware
and because
with ascii it's basically this nested
structure where everything's ascii you
can wrap anything in middleware and then
that that'll perform authentication
um but there's a piccolo api project
then we have a bunch of authentication
middleware there so it's quite easy
um next question
how
can piccolo execute plain sql yeah it
can so you take any any table
name um so i could do
uh
movie dot raw
and then like select star from movie
it's not the
uh i want to remind everybody that you
can follow up also
in slack i just send the hashtag
if you want to because
we have to finish
sharp
so you have two minutes
okay cool
um how does piccolo compare to pony or
um so pony uses a lot of
like list comprehensions that's kind of
it's it's thing
i don't know what the story is with
ponyo and with async but the reason
piccolo was started was there were like
no async rams when it started it's quite
an old project already it's like three
years old so that was really the driving
force
um so there's definitely similarities
sorry differences in the async support
um
what else do we have
just to clarify as a beginner what is
piccolo compared to sql alchemy
so sql alchemy is like a very
established orm so they also have async
support now but they didn't for quite a
while and i think sql alchemy supports a
lot of databases but piccolo our main
focus is being like a really great
postgres database
and
really just having like the full
experience so as i've shown it's a
little bit more than an orm it kind of
has a lot of batteries included so it's
not as fully fledged as durango it's a
bit more flexible in that you can use
any library you like
um
and then the admin is clearly a huge
thing for piccolo that's one of the
driving forces as well um but sql
alchemy is kind of like
a very fully featured like pure orm
so you can't go wrong really with either
um okay i think we're out of time
without questions i just want to say
thank you everyone for listening and i
hope it was useful
thank you thank you for your
presentation and thank you everybody for
joining and i will stop the recording
thanks everyone